welcome to the Keel test make some pork
chops
you will kill
match set of curved guitars
while the Qatar was immensely popular in
India during the 16th and 17th century
this curved version is extremely rare
and has been hailed as one of the most
unique weapons in history the ornate
handle construction features two bars
for the grip and provides the user
enough control to make a very effective
fighting knife as a pair the curved
guitars were designed to deliver quick
and lethal stabs and slashes using both
arms today this one-of-a-kind weapon can
be seen on display at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
dynamic kill test
Mike your first you ready I'm ready
all right Mike just talk about your
curve guitars here for a match set not
bad they're almost identical in the feel
of your weapon your edges are sharp and
overall sir
you'll kill it's great to hear
Matthew you ready yes sir let's have fun
foreign
Matthew let's talk about your curved
guitars here first up I like the scale
of your blades because guitars are the
well the big daddies of push daggers and
push daggers are relatively small so
there's a scale that goes with it to
make it easier to control and I think
you've got that with your blades the
factory gives also a nice support when
I'm stabbing and slashing overall sir
your curved qatars you will Keel thank
you
[Music]
all right gentlemen Welcome to our
Dynamic strength test the Kendo stick
chop and Ballistic tube sliced
Mike you're up first you ready yep let's
do it okay
[Music]
foreign
Mike right off it's an interesting way
to build these it's a non-traditional
way but the issue I have is that there's
so much space around my hands that they
they kind of are trying to find what's
comfortable the other thing that I've
noticed is your blade is really no
longer in line with the handle
but good Cutters they held up nice and
done thanks Dave Matthew you ready let's
do it okay
so Matthew write off good traditional
look to these I like that a lot they cut
like they're supposed to cut they're
plenty strong they held their Edge
beautifully good job thank you
placements there is nothing easy about
fighting this Forge and the two of you
prove yourself in the final round with
some unique blades now unfortunately
only one of you go home today with the
win today's Fortune fire Champion is
Matthew congratulations man Mike you
fought hard your talented Smith but
unfortunately you're not taking home the
wind today I'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor thank
you Mike thank you sir good fight Mike
pretty bummed right now a lot of highs
and a lot of lows and here we are
Matthew that makes you today's Fortune
fire Champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
how you feeling fantastic I feel elated
been a hard Challenge from the first
round to the last
I'm just on cloud nine right now
the sword of Mercy
the sword of Mercy also known as Cortana
has been used as a coronation sword
since the Middle Ages the ceremonial
blade is defined by its square-blooded
tip the legend has it the sword was
broken off by an Angel to prevent a
wrongful killing and therefore
symbolizes the mercy it's named for to
this day this benevolent blade is one of
the crown jewels of the United Kingdom
and is still in use in coronations of
kings and queens today although even
commoners can see it on display in the
jewel house at the Tower of London
basements welcome to the Keel test
run your first you ready for this make
some pork chops
all right we want to talk about your
sword of mercy here
these are sharp chops each cut was very
deep followed by the nice weight that's
backing up the sword it cuts deep into
this big carcass and of course as you
can see it's easy to wield and follow
through and control your weapon overall
sir your weapon it'll kill
all right Sean your turn you ready yes
sir let's do this
I'm pretty nervous I don't know these
things can be pretty gnarly to blades so
I'm just hoping that mine goes clean
through
all right Sean let's talk about your
sword of mercy here I'm able to hold on
to it I can tell where the edge is
but your blader is not very sharp as you
can see the first Cuts right there it's
more from blunt force trauma but as you
can see with the first six inches here
you have some spots that are sharp and
that's sure is what made your blade
heal
blades Miss Welcome to our strength test
it's a throne shop
around you up first you look excited oh
yeah it's overthrowed monarchy let's do
it
all right Ron good job edges are still
razor sharp but that shock wave is
traveling all the way down this blade
and
your guard's loose now
but it was comfortable in the hand
good job thank you
hey Sean how you feeling awful
let's hope you feel better in a few
minutes let's hope
foreign
good job
thank you
all right Sean it's all in one pace
gotta be proud of that for your blade
it's still straight this way
not this way
your handle it's not loose but it's
definitely separated from the base of
the handle now but like I said it's
still in one piece good job thank you
sir
all right blade Smith now it's time to
find out just how sharp your weapons are
this is the sharpest test the tapestry
slice
run your up first you ready oh yeah I'm
speaking pretty all right let's do it
hold on thank you
all right one first stop
it is loose but it did not affect my
test overall sir your Edge you will cut
awesome
all right Sean your turns are you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
thank you
all right Sean around this area right
here you have some sharp edges so you
can see on the first cut here in this
tapestry it cut in but when I'm dragging
through it just stops its cut
but it still did cut so
you'll cut thank you sir
well blade space this has been a good
competition right from the very
beginning but as you know only one of
you guys can leave here with the title
of Fortune fire Champion carrying a
check for ten thousand dollars now our
judges discuss your blades and I'm not
going to leave you in the dark any
longer
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Ron congratulations now Sean you fought
hard your talent Smith but unfortunately
your blade did not make the cut I'm
gonna have to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor thank you all for
having me thank you good job Sean
the whole thing was sharp and I guess I
was wrong I'm definitely gonna go home
bust out a bunch of knives and make sure
all those suckers are sharp as hell
Ron congratulations that makes you the
forge of fire Champion man and you got a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
[Applause]
I'm I'm so proud I would encourage
anyone to come and try this experience
it doesn't matter whether you're new to
bleedsmithing or you're a seasoned
veteran if I can do it at 50 you can do
it at 25.
this is the Vaquero machete
the Vaquero machete became widely
popular with the original Cowboys of the
Southwest during the 20th century
featuring a thin slightly curved blade
the weapon was much lighter and easier
to carry than the larger machetes
previously used by the Cowboys making it
ideal to deliver damaging slashes and
chops on everything from brush to
enemies on the great Frontier
the rich history and culture of the
Cowboys who carry this weapon can be
found on display at the Bullock Museum
in Austin Texas
howdy partners
welcome to the Keel test
your Vaquero machetes look beautiful but
how lethal are they to find that out I'm
going to take care of machetes to
deliver some lethal blows on this big
carcass Greg you feel lucky oh very
lucky all right let's do this
foreign
Greg the leather wrapping that you have
here is nice and smooth the handle is oh
void the one thing though that's just a
lot of handle and because you have a
smooth handle right here a couple of
times my hand just slid down
but your edges are sharp those are razor
sharp Cuts well we're all sir you will
kill thank you Doug
Eric your turn are you ready let's do it
let's do this
foreign
what I like about it is that it just
fits my hand perfectly so it's locked in
there now your Edge that's a Chevron
right there all the way up those are
very sharp deep Cuts even on thrusting
overall sir
you will Keel into here
Oliver carols Welcome to our strength
test the fence board and skull chop
hey Greg you're up first you ready yes
sir
Greg right off blade hell up beautifully
this thing is just the sharpest one I
started feels like a great fighter to me
only complaint I have is that long
handle but other than that the Artistry
is really well done that's a joy to use
nicely done thank you
Eric you ready let's do it all right
all right so first off Eric very
different grind on this edge with that
secondary bevel but it's wicked sharp
and it's still sharp held up fine didn't
lose any blade at all no rolls no chips
nothing but still
as straight as when I started good job
awesome thank you
late Spitz welcome
the Gunslinger slice
[Music]
Greg you up first you ready for this
absolutely all right
foreign
Greg
nicely done those are very sharp clean
cuts on I'd say at least three layers of
clothing your weapon
it will cut
thank you
Eric your turn sir ready let's do it
let's do this
[Music]
foreign
Eric the edges are sharp enough to cut
through all layers and expose some of
the blood overall sir your weapon
you'll cut thank you
all right gentlemen well I gotta say
both of you impressed us from the very
beginning of this competition the first
two rounds you guys crushed it but this
competition as you know only one of you
can leave here as a fortune fire
champion and receive that check for ten
thousand dollars
the fortune fire Champion is
Eric congratulations you did it well
Greg I hope you had as much fun working
here as we had watching you that is an
unbelievably stunning piece but
unfortunately the time this competition
has ended I want to say thank you for
coming but at this point in time I have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you
no shame coming in second to this young
man the check would have been nice the
title would have been nicer but remember
I'm still the fastest blade in the West
well Eric you are the fortune fire
champion and you're receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
[Applause]
never thought I'd be here at this young
I don't even know how to react it feels
surreal from start to finish it's been a
crazy crazy competition and my uncle he
was probably my biggest drive to Win It
uncle Chuck this was for you
the Tibetan sword
the Tibetan sword also called the
dapadam traces its Origins back to the
calm region of Eastern Tibet during the
18th century
this straight single-edged blade
features an oblique tip perfect for
delivering fast fatal slashes and deep
deadly thrusts on an enemy combatant
while Warriors carry this Fierce sidearm
into battle it was most commonly worn by
Tibetan Chieftains in royalty while the
Tibetan sword is no longer used in
combat this weapon can still be seen
today at the Metropolitan Museum of Art
in New York City
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your Tibetan swords can do
Joshua first you ready for this may as
well all right let's do this I am
nervous
all right Josh in swinging your Blade
The Edge you have is sharp
each chop and slice in there is very
beef overall sir your weapon it'll kill
thank you Doug
all right Cliff here turns for you ready
oh yes let's do it let's do this
pigs are no joke it'll absorb a blade
and snap that sucker off
[Music]
all right Cliff your Pummel looks great
but if it was metal it would help with
the bounce to bring it back a little bit
rather to be very forward heavy The Edge
you have here is very sharp and with the
weight pushing it it cut the pig all the
way through overall sir your Tibetan
sword it'll kill
yep
all right gentlemen welcome to Ceramics
with Dave our strength test
remember it's not about what your blades
do to these pots but with these pots due
to your blades and Josh you are up first
break the pots not the blade I'll do my
best
[Music]
oh wow all right Josh it's a very nicely
balanced weapon but
that extremely acute Edge you have there
has taken some damage still completely a
viable blade good job
all right Cliff you're up are you ready
Smash and Bash
[Music]
foreign
cliff without the counterbalance it's
very forward heavy it makes it a slower
blade to fight with and control now
getting up on your blade here
very similar damage in that there are a
lot of very small Nicks and chips out of
your Edge
but it's still in one piece so well done
thank you
all right blades Vince this is the
sharpest test the rug slice
Josh you're first ready for this as well
let's do it
by Josh as you can see this section that
took some damage
it cuts but you can feel it get hung up
on the rug but overall sir you will cut
thanks Doug
all right Cliff your turns are you ready
yes sir let's do this
foreign
[Music]
cliff in the areas that took damage on
the strength test you can see that they
ripped some pieces of the rug the
forward weight of this you can see it
easy lends to coming down look when
you're cutting up it's harder to wield
but overall sir it will come thank you
all right Josh Cliff we wanted to bring
Tibetan swords that were sharp that were
strong and wieldable and both of you did
exactly what we asked but in this
competition there can only be one
Fortune fire Champion today's Fortune
fire Champion is
Josh congratulations
now Cliff unfortunately your Tibetan
sword didn't make the cut today your
time to flip the script competition has
ended I'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the fourth floor
thank you for having me thank you
thank you am I a little disappointed yes
but I've been challenged in a really
really good way so I have a lot to be
thankful for
well Josh you were the newest Forge and
fire Champion you got yourself a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you guys how do you feel
fantastic I never thought I would be at
this moment it's truly a blessing to be
where I am right now it was hard fought
and I'm incredibly grateful to be here
this has been an unreal experience
foreign
this is the Naga sword
the Naga sword traces its Origins back
to 16th century India featuring a broad
Square chisel tip this weapon was graded
inflicting powerful deadly chops in
combat
this rare version of the Dow sword was
reserved for the highest level tribal
authorities due to the scarcity of iron
in the area
a few Naga swords still exist it can be
seen on display in the halls of the
British museum in London
ladysmiths welcome to the kill test
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapons will do I'm going to take your
weapons and put some lethal blows or
chops on this big carcass JoJo are you
ready for this let's make some pork
chops you got it
foreign
pork chops you wanted pork chops you got
most of the wheat is right here in the
handle so that really lends itself to a
nice balanced weapon your sword's Edge
over here chops deeply especially that
one swing on the leg and overall
you'll kill awesome
all right Chris your turn so you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
that's what I'm talking about
all right Chris the first thing I notice
about this is just how sharp your Edge
is ground and that lends itself for very
deep cuts and I like to throw back to
the 90s troll hair right there
but overall sir your Naga sword you will
kill thank you sir
all right gentlemen welcome to the
strength test the how to chop
now those houses would be riding on top
of an elephant this test is not about
what your Naga swords do to the how to
but what that how it does to your blades
and JoJo you are up first you ready
I suppose so
foreign
there's there's no damage it's a kind of
an ax grind but on a chopper it works
fine it held up beautifully in strength
test well done thank you
Chris you ready to play with the how to
yes sir all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Chris I'm going to start back here on
your handle um I like this it's got a
fairly traditional look to it as far as
your blade goes we have a little bit of
an issue your Edge has deflected
over to one side
but it's still sharp other than that I
think it did a good job well done
bladesmits welcome to the sharpest tests
of Jackfruit and rope slice
JoJo go first you ready for this
absolutely all right let's do this
foreign
overall
needle cut thank you
all right Chris your turn sir you ready
yes sir all right let's do this
[Music]
foreign
so in cutting the Jackfruit this section
went here met the jackfruits so that
includes this area that took some damage
you can feel a little bit of a drag but
it did not affect it was able to cut
through the Jackfruit and the Rope
overall sir you're a weapon you will cut
thank you
the place miss both your blades tested
well but only one of you can go home
with a fortune fire champion title and a
check for ten thousand dollars our
judges have discussed your blades when
they made a final decision today's
Fortune fire Champion is
foreign
JoJo congratulations
Chris there's no doubting you were an
extremely talented Smith but
unfortunately your time this competition
has ended I'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor all
right thank you all for having me all
right thank you Chris beautiful brother
thank you guys
I think it all came down to the heat
treatment on my blade uh not sure what
went wrong but uh something obviously
did
JoJo congratulations that means you are
the newest Fortune fire Champion not
only that you are the very first father
and son Champion that's ever come
through Fortune Fire Man congratulations
I I cannot wait to get home and tell Dad
this is going to be super cool and he's
going to be just as excited as I am is
this a blade you'll build again
I think I'll make an extra one I need
something to show off at the house
this is so awesome I never thought I'd
be here and man it's just a blessing
JoJo's the forge and fire Champion let's
go up top yeah
what's up